next up welcome avail
we have available
with embedded normativity so thanks aval
to you
hello can you hear me yep
and can you see the slides bomb I only
see the top left of the slide
you only see this the top left
yeah just yeah try again thank you
okay
Yep looks great thank you
okay good
so I am uh
I'm interested in multiscale Collective
organization this is why I came talks in
France to begin with
and the core question I've been asking
is um basically when we look at humans
organization there is great Evolution
there is a challenge through time of the
specific patterns that are enacted and
this is very hard to account for and I
have been trying to pin down more and
more specifically what exactly is going
on and how to model it so this specific
work is a work I wrote in the context of
what my PhD of course which is funded by
The Escape project a project in a
cognitive archeology that's interesting
interested sorry in how the culture the
archaeological landscape shape cognition
and vice versa the title of it is
normativity an active inference of
agency
an active inference account of agency BM
flash because you will see very quickly
why
so first we will go through the existing
work on ankle technician in the context
of active in France then we'll try to
expose the concept of embedding motivity
which we introduce here
and what it means and then we'll look at
the more semiotic question around the
externalization and utilization of
normativity in
cultural landscapes
so first encrypted coordination inactive
inference
so we interact in France I will go
quickly over it I still need to do it
because there are Lookers that are not
familiar
so active in front say that
agent continuously predicts the specific
queue sensory cues they will see and
they predict the action or policy they
will not take and they basically enact
uh an ongoing stream of expectation that
they reconstruct given you know a coming
signal
so this is best accounting for in this
schema which shows the agent as the
medical system which engage through
environment
through action and cessations and all of
this
um specific
domains they minimize a specific
function that is called free energy and
whose minimization basically means there
is a productive process going on
and a core property effective in France
is that it dissolves agency as we
typically understand it we don't have
agents that have like internal monologue
that drives them to take decision we
have a constitution dissipation of
what's going on and whatever an agent in
space itself to do it will do
and so this goes for
computationally satisfying but very
definitionary notion of what is going on
with agency
so the question then comes uh what is
the relation between an agent and the
cognitive landscape in which it evolves
uh I will present very rapidly again the
framework of skill and functionality if
you're nearby Bruno's
and which says that skill agents which
we understand as agents that understand
what is going on around them they will
basically experience the world as a
landscape of affordances which is
opportunities for actions
and they will their cognition pretty
much reduces to the experience of the
Sunscape and adaptive engagement with it
which basically maximize the grip the
agent as on the system
and essentially for reasons we will not
go over because it's math
the very uh existence experience of this
landscape it is equivalent to the
existence of constraints of our
attention the attention that the agent
gives to thing which uh translates the
emerald expectation that are at least
two times but the more expectation that
the agent enacts
and so this becomes very interesting
when we you know cross it with the
existence of encaturation in humans
because the basic experience we have of
affordances of what we can do it is uh
shapes culturalities shaped by social
interaction when we learn uh with other
humans about what we do what we can do
and what we can do and this means that
the basic human experience it's a
thoroughly encultured it's embedded in
what ROM said called a cultural
landscape landscape of cultural
affordances
and it is embedded in cultural and
material
[Music]
regimes of attention so ways to pay
attention to things
and this is a figure that comes I
believe from this year on
thinking throughout the minds where it
shows basically and how the actual
installation cycle when we have the
Civil agent they build a common
environment that has epistemic cues on
how the world is like and when we are
incarcerated to pay attention to things
in a certain manner that makes it so we
perceive and enact this this landscape
and so the uncultured constraint of all
the improve attention because of the
what we saw just before the deflationary
account of agency it means that the very
expensive landscape cultural landscape
that is collectively enacted it
effectively integrates intentionality
and it effectively integrates
normativity in a way that Clash is
strongly with classical account of both
so given this state of the art let us
look at what I mean specifically about
embedding normativity so a marine
motivity is a kind of formativity I
think you have you have got it
so normal activity it means basically
the criterions by which we judge things
to be good and bad
in the context of biological system they
will look for specific I don't know
chemical concentration and I will avoid
other this is the phenomena of
chemotaxis this is pretty basic and this
is a form of normativity
but for humans we will typically think
of you know laws cultural norms
um there's really shared way to judge
Behavior
and again at least in the context of
flow and choice Theory
it's because you think there is an agent
he has access to information and we'll
think what should I do and He will judge
uh rationally about what is good and
what is bad based on a collection of
values which are internal to the agent
this is not how it works
um
what I call embodied motivity is by
contrasts regimes of normal activity
where it is the uh the norms and value
that guide the agent's Behavior it is
embellished in the material and cultural
environment so basically the agent
projects a specific set of norms and
value in his very experienced princess
environment
and it will perceive the locus of
normativity as the environment and not
as a form of internal judgment
um
let us look at what can exactly how
amazing motivity work it will be more
concrete
so first we can materially constrain
people to do things so for example there
are roads you can go off-roads but it's
harder and you can't really do that if
you're a chariots so when you have a
specific pattern of roads which is
constructed by cities
uh you were pretty much constrained to
follow the roads materially and for this
we will talk of structural embedding
and there is another regimes of motivity
where we build on environment that will
basically queue you suggest you into uh
adopting specific norms and specific
values for example Escape
things that vertical patterns in
archaeological culture
they are somehow embedded within uh what
we call vertical Norms so hierarchy and
certification in Social relationship
and for this specific form of mudding we
control customers compelling
I'm what is must be very clear is that
we don't have structural embedding on
one side and cementing embedding you
know there are basically two mechanism
complementary mechanism in which
normative sorry embedded multivity
occurs if we look at the city so this is
a
impression of Sumerian culture
city-states
we have a matter organization that
prompts specific kind of behavior so for
example we have a bridge and this bridge
allow you constrain you to go through
the river in a specific way if you are
on foot
but this particular constraints it is
perceivable so by using the bridge you
will also see that you can navigate the
world in this specific way
so you don't have aspiration between
semantic and structural embedding we
just have two ways in which
um constraints of our behavior that are
embedded in the environment work
and
something that is a core to the account
of Emily normativity is again that it is
not internal but we need to go into more
detail about what we mean by not being
internal because of course we're talking
about agency agents constrain what
agents do it's not outside
uh what it is is
um
and Marine motivity is a regime of the
motivity where the norms and value they
stem from the experience of foreigns for
example if I see a fire I will not think
about
hey could I put my hand in it and get my
hand burn
I think it will be painful I won't do
that
if I even think about putting my hand in
the fire I will immediately feel bad the
normativity it's embedded in my
experience of the world
I feel like the fire or more
specifically the possibility of putting
my hand in the fire is intrinsically
balanced I do not feel there is a
possibility that is neutral and then I
judge it to be bad
but uh of course this uh this judgment
does not occur outside even if I feel
like it's about my references it emerges
from the argument I have with the
material and cultural niche in which I
find myself
and if we want to
um
to untangle what this mean precisely you
will have to go into more detail into
the what I call the externalization
internalization of anonymatility
so let us look at something very simple
how normativity work for embodied agents
celebrate agents they do ceilings with
hopefully in a niche that is material
and this Niche will be marked by the
activity of my agent and these marks
they can then act as constraints either
through structural augmentating
embedding in the age environment because
like basically signify that in the past
I wanted to do that maybe doing that is
you know good
for example uh we have Centuries with I
don't know if century is a English word
but we have path if uh animals that have
legs this is actually important work uh
sorry work on a specific path they will
compact the Earth and it will become
improper to grow anything even grass and
you will have a path that will emerge
that are pretty it's pretty visible and
I'll tell you hey not only this Earth is
Compact and allow you to walk on its
like without effort but also this has
been widely judged to be um
to be a Goods uh
Outlook outline for navigation in this
specific environment
so the very experience of a bath
basically invites you it affords you
perceive the affordance of working
through the path
and this is something that again can
result from your own activity that can
be returned into the amendment by your
own activity
and solve this begs the question of how
okay there exists embedded normativity
but how do we embed normativity what is
the activity of embedding motivity like
and the word I will use for that is
externalization we perceive the world
because we externalize uh specific
causes of sensation into an imagined
objectives on the world
so when we see the path
we see a path we do not see compact
Earth that we then compute to mean that
other things have worked on it we just
see hey there is a path
and this is because we have externalized
a specific cognitive kind which is the
path
and this is a argument that
seropital Mains here are Lena in
steinler which if I remember well
um worked on the um the production of
devices that help blind people see
things through
I believe an array of Repertory device
on their shoulder so the core
argument they make is that if you give
people that they will start seeing
things they will start pursuing things
as being before them rather than having
Liberation on the shoulder and then
thinking about oh what does it mean and
so the basic argument is that perception
is just
um picture of what cause we infer what
is the structure we infer of environment
given the existence of a specific
coupling device that relates action to
sensation and vice versa
and this critically relies on the
internalization of specific we could say
a lot of things that I will say priors
specific prior is not an interception
so missing the path as a path relies on
me having the prior knowledge that there
is such a thing as past and I should be
expecting to see them around
and so you have um duality of
externalization and internalization in
the production of a marine motivity I
can only see Norms out there if I've
internalized integrated or specific
apparatus of perception that entails
that they are indeed those specific
Norms that are embedded in those
specific references
and so this uh produce a marginal
question of symmetics basically of
information Theory
how do reading and writing motivity
works
uh so one extent lies I treat the world
as having specific natural categories
that I pretty much imagine
and I can use them because I can adjust
them as an extended memory that allow me
to read and write normative cues uh this
can be um you know letters uh pure signs
but as far as I'm concerned here all
signs are at least implicitly narrative
there about how you should interpret the
design
and this means that we can experience a
specific landscape or forenses and we
can
we can write things out there we can
write formative cues biobehavioral that
will then constrain further Behavior but
nothing tells us that we can
that we can
communicate with this the communication
it works because of the internalization
of prayers if a given community of
agents are initialized a specific set of
priors that is a set of pairs that
enable externalization of the narrative
cues then only it can use the
environments as a way to
two rights and reads normative cues as a
embedding normativity thing
and this communication it can be read in
terms of information theory of course
can you write in terms of semantics but
what is uh critical to analyze that the
process of internalization it is there
there is no um trust system there is no
private key that allows you to be sure
that the way you utilize Norms is very
specifically uh the way in which the
amylene Nativity was encouraged to begin
with there is a loss or there is
ambiguity or there is I'd rather say it
like this an active damage of
reconstruction of given priors by the
agents and so this gap between the
intent of other communicants and my
intents my understanding of what I meant
by their active engagement active
engagement with the world it builds a
tiny Gap in information that is somehow
enough to drive the opinion evolution of
cultural landscape and this is something
that I do not think is a marriage
inactive in France and I think is of
major interest to research
to the research at least in the
evolution of open-end evolution of
crucial landscape
so uh to sum up things
uh I just presented the paper that is
called animismativity and that speaks
and surprisingly enough of embedded
normativity
uh first major point is that effective
inference is correct then
um our notion of agencies dissolved
essentially in the notion that we can
perceive and enact cognitive landscape
if you want
and given that this is the case
we will experience the norms and value
that guy or behavior as a property of
you know the cognitive landscape
experience the affordance that we can
perceive
and these specific regime of normativity
I call embedded normativity
and the third thing is that you have a
critical thing going on any other
symmetically constraining thing going on
in the externalization internalization
of regimes of embelline nativity
because those two things they
respectively enable Nomad interactivity
to exist to have causal power
and the enable also the operating
evolution of the Norms that are embedded
in a given landscape in a given measure
landscape and therefore the operating
evolution of the excited cultural or
cognitive landscape
so thank you I will uh enroll my
references slides in case someone has
the really needs to know what the
reference season is ready to move around
the video for this
and do you have questions
awesome thank you avail
while people are typing any questions
could you maybe just give a little
introduction to the active inference for
the social sciences course like what
brought you to want to
facilitate this effort and where are we
at and where do you want it to go what
do you want it to be for people
unmute and then continue
good point thank you uh the activity for
institute organizes uh and keros
research organize a course on the on
active inference in the social science
that is essentially in explaining the um
and the consequences of the cultural
landscape formalism that I
hinted at slightly in this presentation
the goal of the course is to give a
basic ontology that is on the interface
between complexity science let us say
physics written large
cognitive Science Central science to
afford interdisciplinary collaboration
in the
in the social science and in the study
of the evolution of human societies
and I think it is cool
but then I asked because I have a nice
date some maybe you should ask Daniel
which is absolutely embiased whether the
course is cool
I I've been enjoying it a lot uh we just
finished last week with my section on
Collective Behavior
first we had the introduction lecture
from you then Ben White on the basics of
being an active agent and we have Lorena
and Mao's sections upcoming as well as
your more dedicated session yeah it's
been a really
fun uh
uh experience and it's going to provide
a really useful
missing piece
in the ecosystem I guess just one
question I have how do we take some of
these
topics you're bringing in about the
embedded normativities and think about
them digitally like are we talking about
conceptual embeddedness in information
environments and or are we talking about
the ergonomics of sitting at our desk or
how do we bring that kind of pleasure
path
stigmergy on the grounds
into the digital are we talking about
something that's
embodied and embedded
in the information space or are we still
talking about bodies
we talk about bodies with the brain
needs that do things in Virtual
environments but your question is I'm
not sure on the studies how can we bring
these specific Concepts in the study of
digital film Twitter internets
yeah is that it yeah okay
the whole study on the affordances you
have a
so the recipient of design has
incorporated a while ago the national
performance in its structure and most of
the study in the digital design center
or what uh platforms are for or do not
afford
and you have a richer stance when you
take into account not what you can do
with a specific interface but what the
specific interface invites you to do
given a set of cultural
written knowledge it can be self
learning but given a set of power that
you share with
with the um
platform in a way that is a
formal but indirect
and
um
so yes I would look at it in terms of in
user interface design I think this
concept specifically is useful for
um
for interface design
then you will have implicitly the
question of the floor that platforms
such as I don't know Twitter Facebook
how specific structural environment
brings specific Collective dynamics that
might be a bit richer
not ritual specifically but that might
go in a direction that the usant face
question do not go into
and that can still be modeled in terms
of constraints and therefore in terms of
embed normativity is that on point we'll
go to a question
um
yeah that's interesting about
what the interface does and then what it
invites it might invite things
in order for that invitation to be
fulfilled it has to actually provide
that possibility
but it might invite things that that
aren't relationally possible like there
might be a wall which invites climbing
to a given Observer yet they cannot
climb it and then on the other side
is
a capacity that isn't invited and
that is the
the adjacent possible of tool use
where something that was being used for
this purpose it's like all of a sudden
it just fell out of someone's hand they
grasped it a different way it invited a
different engagement and then that can
become re-entrenched and that points to
that sequential like making and breaking
of new spaces that your work has
featured over the last few years
yeah exactly this work has been
developed with uh while thinking about
tool use while thinking about the
cognitive archeology we're thinking
about the experience of cities the way
urbanism from specific behavior
but
um if I can get back on the internet
thing I'd like to make it more specific
so the interface design as far as I know
is focused on interface what is it that
is not surprising
but in doing so it is focused on
specific Forums on what you can do you
have another layer in uh ecological
psychology which is the layer of
solicitation so for example on Twitter
there's something very specific which is
when you log in it shows you it shows
you the number of authentication you
have then it removes it and you have to
wait to know which were those
sanctification and you have to wait no
once again not one minute but a random
amount of time so this is uh what they
call dark patterns they are patterns in
design that are explicitly designed to
create addiction so this is a layer you
can't afford in reference because
yeah from a foreign
motivation and the way uh specific
structural environment is perceived the
cinematics semantics Maybe
the meaning that given landscape has for
an agent and even if you look at this
you are still still looking at the
platform in a way that is um
is embedded from these specific patterns
that specific patterns of things that
people do on the platform if you have
Twitter without the aggressive
Securities and the um why to
aggressively signal that you are in
whatever it is is going on you don't
have Twitter much of Mastodon maybe
that's us very similar affordances and
very very very dissimilar solicitation
so this is this is why you have to to
take a multi-scale account of things and
when you take them it's kind of kind of
things you have to look at the semiotics
particular Behavior how specific
coordination occur at specific scales
around specific communication specific
message passing
and once you look at how specific
message become meaningful to specific
agent you are
you you have a problem basically because
this is subjectively this is constructed
through the activity of the agent and
this is uh whatever is the
range of time you are looking at you
will have the construction of new
possibilities of adjacent possible as
you put it
and yeah this is the this is the uh big
question that I think we are missing at
the moment inactive in France
awesome well thank you for this
presentation thanks for the social
sciences work and we're all looking
forward to
see how the projects play out
thank you everybody
farewell Avel